welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
batman matt reeves detective noir take
on the caped crusader also known as the
world's greatest detective in this case
played by robert pattinson not always
the world's greatest detective in the
story but hey it's only his second year
into it and the movie is all the better
for it this is one of my favorite
cinematic depictions of gotham and its
broken broken toys there's so much to
appreciate about this film the clues
reeves hid throughout this film to set
up the mystery subtle details in the
camera work in the music and easter eggs
pointing to the broader dc universe my
favorite kind of movie to break down and
i'm gonna do it scene by scene spoilers
ahead here we go and big thanks to boxu
for sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later oh by the way i am
wearing our custom design of gotham noir
a shirt available for a limited time at
new rockstarsmerch.com it's really the
best way to support what we do here so
the film opens with the abrupt title
text of batman filling the screen
actually the way the 2019 joker opening
title text filled that screen but here
it's kind of like one of bruce's red
tinted snapshots taken from his eye
lenses filling in all of his vision this
film constantly shows extreme close-ups
of eyes and fingers objects objects so
close we can't really distinguish them
as well as the point of view shots from
those peepers a reflection of this
film's shifting points of view that keep
us guessing who the real villains of the
story are the opening shot is actually
one of these povs from under the mask of
the riddler his breath sucking through
his military cold weather mask as he
peers through binoculars a recurring
voyeurism as we later see batman doing
the same thing to selena kyle this
opening shot is reminiscent of john
carpenter's opening point of view shots
in the movie halloween a silent boy
killer heard only by his heavy breathing
from behind his mask the riddler's gaze
passes a cop guard sitting at the gate
didn't you see seinfeld you never give
them a chair to sit in there's lots of
holes in the security but then he lands
on a boy dressed as a ninja inside
pretend killing his father before
heading out to trick-or-treat we've been
primed by so many batman films to expect
the first skin we see to be a young
bruce wayne especially since christopher
nolan's batman begins explored bruce's
backstory as a ninja but this flips a
script on us revealing it to be the son
of the corrupt mayor don mitchell jr yet
still this is a grieving boy that batman
will later feel a connection with now
the music over all this is schubert's
ave maria sung by a boy falsetto a
recurring track setting up the riddler's
history as a choirboy orphan framed in a
press photo with the wayne family ave
maria is a common funeral hymn it
actually plays later at the mayor's
funeral and then again back at the
orphanage and if you listen closely
throughout this film the composer
michael chiaquino uses a minor key
rendition of ave maria as the riddler's
theme music
now opening on halloween night is
definitely a nod to the long halloween
the first real great batman detective
storyline from the comics a story that
ties heavily into the falcons and the
maroons other comic influences were
batman year one and cook's ego both arcs
you definitely want to read but really i
gotta say matt reeves clearly made this
movie its own thing and you could just
point to anything in this movie and say
it was from any comic book ever but this
movie is better appreciated for its
cinematic details not as just a list of
comic book easter eggs so that's the
approach i'm gonna go in this breakdown
because speaking of carpenters halloween
there is a great michael myers-esque
reveal of the riddler directly behind
the mirror only revealed when the tv
light flickers brighter like batman the
riddler first appears to us from the
shadows but never steps out of those
shadows until he is ready to kill not
giving his prey an opportunity to see
him and make a different choice now this
riddler look with the glasses over the
mask is inspired directly from the
descriptions of the zodiac killer who
also taunted police and the media with
mysterious ciphers written in his own
alphabet he clubs the mayor with a
tucker a tool used in carpeting proving
the riddler planned from the beginning
for batman to find this tool and use it
later to uncover his home floorboards to
reveal his long game to bomb the city
sea walls and then we jump to halloween
night from bruce's perspective we
actually start on these weird two
glowing shapes that look like eye holes
from inside his batman cowl but these
extreme close-ups are actually part of
the bat signal igniting steaming in the
rain and you'll notice this bat signal
is not the clean stencil that we have
seen before but a chunk of metal jammed
into the shutters of a standard
searchlight just showing how batman and
gordon are really in the early days of
their partnership also reflected on the
location of this bat signal in this
unfinished construction site then we see
gotham's times square region with a
gotham empire building a holiday in
gotham a bank of gotham the gotham
tribune and then this screen psa warning
addiction to drops on the rise drops
being the name of a new eye drop drug of
this world the guy who robs the store is
actually wearing a green drop mask he's
a literal drop head and this story is
called good times grocery which is an
easter egg to the robert pattinson crime
movie good time which matt reeves said
that he watched while writing this
script for this movie that made him want
to cast robert pattinson and you'll
notice it's almost always raining in
gotham a detail lifted directly from the
movie seven in which david fincher made
sure it was raining in every exterior
shot in the city to show the oppressive
nature of urban life bruce describes how
the gothamites ignore the rain all this
rain setting up the city's eventual
flooding in the third act the more water
the more the criminals are able to
overtake the city batman stalks this
group of thugs wearing white face paint
though you'll notice their initiate
played by jayla sergo who actually plays
tim drake on titans he only has half of
his face painted since he has not yet
earned his full spot in the gang now
after we saw two fake outs where
criminals looked into the shadows of an
alley terrified that batman would step
out of them finally he does here on the
train platform giakino's score evokes
john williams imperial march for darth
vader
and batman's entrance here definitely
recalls darth vader's first arrival
through the smoke in a new hope by the
way the cinematographer on this movie
was greg frazier who also dp'ed rogue
one which had its own iconic darth vader
shots and he introduces himself the hell
are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance yes now this is a year two
batman still getting his name out there
and he's actually called vengeance more
often than he's called batman in this
movie also i am vengeance is part of his
famous three-line phrase from the
nothing to fear episode in batman the
animated series i am vengeance
i am the knight i am
batman batman tazes the last guy on the
throat showing that batman's armor
itself must be electro proof setting up
how he survives getting shocked by that
generator in the flooded arena in the
final act batman joins lieutenant jim
gordon at the mayor's crime scene
showing off some impressive detective
skills deducing the thumb was severed
when the mayor was still alive and
noticing a bloody mark on the floor from
where the murder weapon bounced over
there that even the photographer was
like oh what's he looking at oh damn i
should snap a shot of this now in a way
he does live up to his title of the
world's greatest detective but i would
argue in this film he's actually not yet
that much of a detective he makes some
crucial errors but it makes for a much
better story especially for someone at
the beginning of his career in
vigilantism on the walls our newspaper
celebrating the mayor's maroney drug
bust referring to the gang of sal
moroney rivals to the falcons the whole
thing we later learned in the movie a
total sham newspapers also include a
subtler headline about the city's sea
wall construction problems teasing the
riddler's final plan to target those sea
walls and then this clue from your
secret friend who having a clue
let's play a game just me and you this
card with the skeleton saying from your
secret friend was modeled directly on
the real life card sent by the zodiac to
san francisco chronicle reporter paul
avery that had a skeleton saying from
your secret pal the riddle is what does
a liar do when he's dead answer he lies
still is decodable using the same double
letter technique cited by robert
graysmith in the zodiac film that's the
most common double consonant in the
english language the double l and what's
the one word that we know that he'll use
in here at least once
you'll notice how later alfred will try
using the same technique to mark off all
the double o's before bruce realizes
that eliminating the six letters that
they were given fills out the riddler's
favorite ryan gosling movie from the
crime scene the music shifts to
nirvana's something in the way with kurt
cobain's lyrics reflecting this grunge
take on batman from robert pattinson a
guy who wishes he was homeless and feels
more comfortable on the streets at night
but also as the final track on nirvana's
never mind album it actually precedes a
secret track that comes after 10 minutes
of silence called endless nameless so
this recurring track in the movie is
really the something in the way of
bruce's true mindset as he is a
detective masking a secretly violent
monster underneath that layer cobain's
lyrics also reference the animals i
trapped referring to the past criminals
that batman has caught in these first
two years and how the riddler literally
traps animals in cages for batman to
find and you'll notice right as bruce
arrives in his bat cave the old wayne
tower subway station of wayne terminus
we hear cobain singing
underneath the bridge tarp has sprung a
leak another indication that the flood
is coming a flood that probably will
actually flood this whole batcave
bruce's moody voiceover has actually
been his journal entry in a notebook
labeled gotham project framing this
batman as a young physician
experimenting with different cures for
the city a doctor like his father a
contrast to the riddler who approaches
the ills of the city as a forensic
accountant looking for and diagnosing
redundancies where the numbers don't add
up but not prescribing true cures to
those discrepancies his first entry in
this film is the night of thursday
october 31st and in the epilogue after
the flood it's the morning of wednesday
november 6th meaning the whole movie
transpires in about six to seven days
but it is the dawn of the seventh day in
genesis it took god seven days to create
the universe but since we are right on
the border between that sixth and
seventh day the sixth day is when god
created man we haven't fully gone
through that seventh day yet a way of
showing how in this movie we have not
yet fully acquired that seventh day of
rest there's still work to be done when
bruce joins alfred for breakfast i love
this he squints at the morning sunlight
and has to put on sunglasses as he is a
self-described nocturnal animal who's
getting too accustomed to seeing
nighttime prey through his special
lenses kind of like morphe's line in the
matrix his eyes hurt because he's never
really used them properly before here on
the ground floor there's actually a bust
of william shakespeare which could be a
possible nod to the 60s adam west batman
when the batcave was accessed by a
button hidden in shakespeare's bust then
in the mayor's garage batman knows which
car to check from the shears and the
tire left there by the riddler the
shears probably used to sever the
mayor's thumb which is why batman then
looks for a usb thumb drive port thumb
drive and they say this movie doesn't
have jokes batman fights his way into
the iceberg lounge and breaks the nose
of the moonlighting cop named bill
kenzie who's actually a narco from the
gotham central comics and batman means
oz cobblebot the penguin there's a great
visual exchange here where he sees
selena kyle boots first and then as
selena exchanges cash for drops with oz
selena quickly recognizes anika from the
photos which batman notices and then
later after talking to oz he sees the
same boots on annika in the photo so
knows for sure that the two must be
involved somehow but then my favorite
detail in this movie comes right after
this as they exit the lounge we're
outside in the upper corner of the frame
there's a lit window showing a
silhouette snapping photos of the lounge
entrance this is the riddler that is how
he got all of these embarrassing photos
this is only 30 minutes into the film
folks but this isn't revealed and
confirmed until two hours later that
nashton's home is across the street from
the lounge and you'll notice this is in
a hotel lit in a green neon sign this is
under our noses from the beginning of
the film i love it then after sparring
with selena batman finds her overdue
electric bills that list selena's
address as queen street and gotham us
there's no state listed because
throughout the comics of the films
gotham's exact location in the united
states tends to shift around the news
reports commissioner savage's murder his
head in a cage fed to snarling rats a
detail from george orwell's 1984 when
winston is tortured in room 101 with his
head in a similar rat cage then when
examining his body batman and gordon
look at the riddler's rat maze with the
new cipher in a linear path in a tray as
a second riddle this time a purple
envelope with a card showing a mad
scientist pouring chemicals i'm mad
about you want to know my name just look
inside and see and then inside an
explosion with but wait i gotta tell you
that might spoil the chemistry of course
teasing the riddler waking up a bomb for
the ta and at the bottom he writes
follow the maze till you find the rat
bring him into the light you'll find
where i'm at batman then teams up with
salinas that she wears his recording
lenses to scan vips in the club here she
meets da gil coulson and as she talks
with them her red wig contrasts with the
blue light on his face which gets colors
to get mirrored at the end of the night
when the riddler straps the neck bomb to
him in the car which reeves and frazier
keep way out of focus just flashing blue
and red lights invoking a police squad
car ironic for him being the arm of the
law but now facing justice for his own
corruption i also really like the detail
of coulson having to wipe the steam off
the windshield since riddler had been
sitting in this parked car all night
steaming it up and as the camera pulls
back from this attack it's all framed
with a gotham sea wall in the foreground
the waves right up to the top super high
tide from all this rain marking this
street corner as one of the targets of
the riddler's later detonations alfred
has translated the maze cipher 2 you are
el rata alada saying that the spanish
isn't perfect since as oz later points
out rata alada is a spanish feminine
noun an adjective meaning it should have
the pronoun of la not l a clue of course
setting up the word play of url also
perhaps a nod to the spelling of
grammatical mistakes throughout the
zodiac's letters and ciphers which some
code breakers believe may have actually
been intentional probably not but most
of these criminals think they're smarter
than they are alfred gives bruce
thomas's wayne family cufflinks a w with
a curved line through it which visually
matches the designs that the riddler
used for many of his symbols hard lines
with curved s-shapes or question mark
shapes snaking through them at the
mayor's funeral bruce gets met with
paparazzi now later in the riddler's
home there's a newspaper clipping wall
of a past bruce wayne tabloid photo with
a smiling face behind him that matches
the smile of barry killen who plays the
joker in an arkham prison cell in one of
the final scenes now i didn't see barry
kyoen in this mom but i just love the
idea that he might have stalked bruce as
one of these photographers in the past
similar to how john doe in seven cameoed
in plain sight earlier in the film as a
paparazzo inside a young man tries to
sneak past a barrier before getting
caught and bruce chats with another
angry father glad that the mayor's dead
both of these men are wearing dull green
and jackets i think they were both among
ridler's followers who later attacked
the rally actually that angry dad is
definitely the same guy who later gets
unmasked on the catwalk and says he's
vengeance now you can see there's a lot
to talk about when breaking down this
amazing film so to fuel me through this
process i've been trying my best to
focus on some interesting choices in my
snacking game and you can take your
snacking on an international adventure
with our friends at baksu boksu is a
monthly subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door baksu partners with family-owned
snack makers to make their original
treats every monthly box is themed this
month's theme is sakura season sakura is
japanese for cherry blossom and the
cherry blossom is an important cultural
symbol in japan and their blooming is a
huge event so every year people
celebrate by gathering under the trees
for flower viewings called hanami and
they have picnics together it's
wonderful as you can see the box is just
packed with all sorts of limited edition
cherry blossom themed snacks and this
booklet that comes with it tells you
everything that's in the box what part
of japan it came from so this is a
sakura mochi from nagano in japan i just
love the texture of mochi i love how
squishy it is oh that's really good
i love mochi so much
it's like i'm eating a pillow that's
hugging my teeth back
so if you want to have your own sakura
celebration and support new rockstars
here click the link in the description
and use the code rockstars to get 15 off
your order but this funeral gets
interrupted
[Music]
i love how for all this we stay inside
the church we only hear the faint [ __ ]
revs the screams the dull pops of the
gunshots all growing louder and louder
until the suv crashes in you'll notice
the riddler painted the letters d-o-a on
the car a joke for the d.a being d-o-a
dead on arrival and using a neck bomb
this way may be inspired by the horrible
incident involving brian wells in 2003
very complex plot that involved theft
and blackmail i'd recommend a
documentary i saw on netflix about that
but i hate that documentary because it
showed the death with zero trigger
warning netflix could you please just
put a little trigger warning before that
part happens or take it out anyway bruce
returns as batman to claim his third
riddle now in a yellow envelope in these
trying times never forget i'm just a
phone call away and then he wrote ring
ring
dozens of times you'll notice the text
gets more and more crammed in toward the
bottom of the card the riddler's live
stream includes comments egging the
riddler on including one that says hope
it's a dud and we gotta do it all again
tuesday a clue for how the riddler
actually plans to blow up the sea wall
on tuesday election day others diss
batman screw the pose room black i need
more riddler and what if that's body
armor i think it'll save him from the
blast indeed it totally does the riddler
asks it can be cruel poetic or blind but
when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice the second riddle
if you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye he's referring to the cost of
coulson's bribes which apparently is 10
000 a month not to prosecute certain
cases which brings us to the third
riddle since your justice is so select
please tell us which vermin you're paid
to protect but because coulson will not
give up the rat
batman clashes with the gcpd but gordon
helps him escape with a dramatic leap
off the tower and wingsuit glide but the
part of the l train that he clotheslines
is actually right next to that neon
green hotel sign so this is right where
the riddler lives he probably saw all of
this go down now suspecting the penguin
is the winged rat they follow into a
drug deal at the recycling plant leading
to this shootout and chase this movie's
batmobile fires up it's a true muscle
car with an exposed engine flames
bursting out the side of the
undercarriage like batman himself he's
ready to explode this street chase is
some of the best action filmmaking i
have seen reeves and frazier mount the
cameras on the sides of the cars to make
us feel like we are looking through the
side view mirror or we're in the back
seat looking out meanwhile the music
that jakino uses here interrupts his
main batman theme with rapid percussive
breaks
so that we only hear the charging theme
when the batmobile gains on the penguin
also they the
which syncs perfectly with a percussion
they pass under some highway signs with
dc references the gotham docks are
freight docks used by organized crime in
the games robinson park is a poor
neighborhood in gotham city where selena
kyle lived during the no man's land
storyline tricorner yards refers to the
tri-corner it's a triangle-shaped island
on the south side of gotham where the
gcpd is located in no man's land and
then hinckley river could refer to south
hinckley a downtown burrow in the gotham
knight anthology film and a location in
dark knight rises and the chase reaches
its climax
as batman approaches oz we see him
framed upside down in the fire upside
down like a bat hanging from above and i
love this after they interrogate the
penguin he waddles after them with his
ankles bound moving just like a penguin
does but the riddler lures them back
into the orphanage that thomas wayne
donated to the city but since his
renewal fund was emptied it fell to ruin
a projector shows thomas's mayoral
campaign announcement beside a group of
choir boys one of whom was edward
nashton and i like how when bruce
realizes he is the next target the
riddler's previous two riddles come back
to haunt him the woman picking up the
phone and the old man blowing up alfred
opening up the explosive package and
dory answering the phone to tell him he
was too late as bruce tries to figure
all of this out laying out the evidence
on the floor an overhead shot positions
him at the center of all this evidence
as his dual rules as both the wayne eyre
and batman make him really the center of
the riddler's plot more centered than
even the riddler realizes selena reveals
falcone is her father as has been the
case in the comics and bruce sees the
riddler's latest video detailing the
histories of the wayne and the arkham
families how reporter edward elliott
uncovered the secret of martha's parents
murdered suicide leading to her being in
and out of arkham for years she was
actually the heiress of the arkham
family riddler wrote over this the word
hush referring to thomas's hush payments
on this story but also a clear nod to
the batman hush storyline another great
detective mystery that also features
batman and catwoman romantically
involved while the riddler orchestrates
this plot from behind bars that
reporter's name being edward elliott
could be a nod to the great grandfather
of thomas elliott aka hush in that
storyline thomas's cease and desist
comes from the law firm of miller and
more an easter egg to the comic writers
frank miller and alan moore who wrote
what i think are the best batman graphic
novels the dark knight returns and the
killing joke respectively falcone tells
bruce that sal moroney had his parents
killed to keep thomas from being a
forever loyal asset to falcone but
alfred clarifies that thomas was
actually planning to sell out falcone to
the police on the night that they were
murdered he could just never verify if
it was actually falcone's doom and i
love love love that this movie keeps it
a mystery selena is able to get the
truth out of kenzie that falcone killed
annika and that falcone was the true
winged rat being protected by city
leaders and ruling over the corruption
of all of gotham as everyone was really
draining thomas's billion dollar renewal
fund the way this mystery unfolds in the
movie parallels the movie chinatown
which explores how the city of los
angeles was built on corrupt dealings
around the city's water infrastructure
including the twist of the top boss
having a secret daughter batman charges
in to stop selena from killing falcone
with an amazing hallway shot from reeves
and frazier lit only by the flashing of
the machine guns just like frasier's
hallway shot in rogue one lit only by
the lightsaber in the blasters falcone
gets arrested and he taunts gordon
saying what are you with zorro here
classically it was outside a screening
of a zorro film where bruce's parents
were killed in the comics which is one
of his inspirations to don a black mask
but the riddler shoots falcone dead and
batman notices this is under a
flickering street lamp bringing the rat
into the light also marking the spot as
one of those blinking christmas lights
in the riddler's floor mat right next to
where a seawall bomb was planted the
riddler surrenders calmly in a diner
with imagery actually matching edward
hopper's painting nighthawks but his
surrender at the end of the film's
second act plus the police's discovery
of his horror show apartment is also
directly from venture 7. both criminals
having thousands of pages of handwritten
ramblings and john doe surrendering to
police as part of his master plan such
as the case for the riddler who calmly
traces a question mark in his drink the
riddler has two ids one for edward
nashton the other for patrick parker
both are known aliases of edward nigma
in the comics the police are able to id
nashton as a forensic accountant thus
how he knew which city leaders were
profiting from the renewal fund and
whether coulson was telling the truth
about his 10 000 bribes and why here all
of his journals are written on ledgers
you'll notice a close-up of one of the
pages shows entries from july reading i
know what i must become a line that he
repeats then over and over and over
below like a student repeating a lesson
as a punishment on a chalkboard what he
must become is a masked vigilante
something he learned from batman whom he
viewed as a silent partner someone he
thought would be impressed with his work
batman finds one more letter in a red
envelope in a bat cage a card with a
proverbial monkey dancing for an organ
grinder this proves that the riddler at
least at first did not know bruce wayne
and batman were the same person if his
plan was to kill bruce with the bomb
that alfred opened and then for batman
to find the see you in hell note
followed by this card riddler must have
thought he could kill bruce wayne and
then celebrate afterwards with batman a
separate person but the way the riddler
whispers his name here grows
away
does make it seem for a beat that the
riddler is saying it to batman to taunt
him but then the scene backpedals when
the riddler comes back to it saying
bruce wayne he's the only one we didn't
get which i think is a great twist
showing how the riddler saw him and
batman working together to bring down
the elites like bruce wayne and he was
just repeating the name out of his own
personal lingering envy for the orphan
who got spotlight instead of him but i
think there is another way to read this
that perhaps after setting his plan into
motion putting those stamps on all the
letters and sending them out when bruce
wayne ended up not dying in the
explosion the riddler might have been
able to conclude that that was because
he led him that night to the orphanage
accidentally keeping his target away
from harm so that maybe now he might
know that they are the same person he's
just not yet revealing that he knows
continuing to tease batman i don't know
i could make an argument either way and
the fact that paul dana walks the line
so carefully so that we're not really
sure how much the riddler knows is what
makes him so great when batman returns
to the realers apartment on his social
media account he finds comments from
others including one who says don't
forget the cling wrap paul dano actually
revealed an interview that originally he
committed to wrapping his whole body in
cling wraps so that the riddler wouldn't
leave any dna at the crime scene so paul
dano eventually just gave up doing that
because uh when you wrap your body in
cling wrap your skin cannot perspire so
the plan comes to fruition in the vans
explode the sea wall caves flooding the
city enacting an old testament disaster
a plague upon the city wiping it clean
and this herds everyone in the high
ground at belarus campaign rally in the
arena where the riddler's followers plan
to open fire but batman drops in takes
them all down fighting alongside selena
at one point he checks himself with
adrenaline he goes full ralphie parker
but floodwater pours in and a loose
electrical cable dangles over the water
so batman swings over and using the
detachable chest emblem blade that we
saw him used before he cuts the cable
knowing that his shock absorbent armor
will protect him i mean i love this
reveal as it confirms my theory from
over two years ago when i demonstrated
how that chess piece could actually be
made into a blade by fully making one
out of cardboard and then stabbing
phillip with it and then he leads the
survivors to safety he has transformed
from a shadow to be feared to a beacon
of hope and for the first time in this
movie as he looks into the daylight he
does not squint meanwhile his voiceover
describes how the flooded city is now at
risk for a new criminal takeover as we
see the penguin gaze out at its new
empire a flooded city perfect for a
penguin a flightless bird but an
excellent swimmer back in arkham barry
killing cameos as the unscreened arkham
prisoner in the cell beside riddlers
saying one day you're up the next you're
a clown laugh you maniacally while
teasing a wide grin a bit of a
disfigured face yes the joker which was
further confirmed by this movie's
post-credit clue directed us back to
ratalata.com where a new cipher revealed
the symbol for the letter z leaving the
only letter left in the riddler's
alphabet still a mystery the letter j
well mr j his new best friend actually
since then a new cipher dropped on the
site translating to you think i'm
finished but perhaps you don't know the
full truth every ending is a new
beginning something is coming still in
all those letters no jay matt reeves
actually confirmed in an interview that
there is a deleted scene in which batman
after seeing the riddler's clues
pointing to him in particular did
actually meet with the joker face to
face in arkham to consult with him i
guess kind of like chloe starling
consulting with hannibal lecter and he
indicated that it might show up on the
blu-ray release in the final scene
selena says she is planning on moving to
bloodhaven a neighboring city in the
comics known as the base of operations
of nightwing but batman does not follow
her and she says who am i kidding you're
already spoken for now yes this is
something alfred says in the year zero
comics but as elena says it her eyes
dart to the left her eye line is
connecting with the bat signal in the
sky that was the first image we saw
associated with batman in the very
opening minutes of the movie while this
movie at times flirted with being a bat
in the cat story i think its strongest
partnership was really between batman
and gordon it is a detective story
however they were not in this movie the
world's greatest detectives honestly
they screwed up constantly their spanish
was bad the only way they caught the
riddler was because he surrendered to
them the city sea walls still imploded
the city's left flooded you could argue
that they completely failed their
riddler investigation really the victory
belongs to the riddler here the most
corrupt leaders of gotham are now out of
the picture but that makes batman's
victory in this movie a personal one he
started the movie blind now we can see
by losing the battle of this movie it
sets him up to win the longer war and it
shows us that work always needs to be
done while this may be the dawn of the
seventh day it is not the time for rest
i obviously love this movie and i love
it more and more each time i watch it
the more i talk about it hopefully
diving into the details helped you
appreciate it more too hey a reminder
that you can get this limited edition
gotham noir shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you